hello and welcome to the second Python
debugging tutorial series in the last
video we were talking about name error
and in this tutorial we're going to be
talking about unbound local error and
they're kind of similar in what causes
this error and both of them basically
have a variable reference before the
assignment so let's go ahead and run
through this and explain what's going on
so the first thing is we need a variable
so we'll define x equals five and now
what we're going to do is to find a
function so we're gonna say define test
and normally we would in case this and
try and accept however in the interest
of showing you guys a nasty ugly read
output that comes from an error I'm not
gonna do it but normally I would say you
should put your from prior year yeah
your function and trying to accept but
anyway moving right along maybe all we
want to do is print X and so when we do
that X is corresponding up here which
actually makes X a global variable so
when we run this it should actually
print out five for us so we'll run test
and there it is five but it only worked
because we didn't that attempt to modify
X so now what if we did X plus equals
one well I'm gonna spoil it for you guys
and tell you this isn't gonna work so
you run it and sure enough you get an
error because X is being referenced
before its assignment which is kind of
funky because it's like it knew what X
was here but now it doesn't what though
but anyway what's actually happening is
you're trying to manipulate X but it has
no idea what X really is so how do we
get around this because maybe you really
want X to be a global variable because
maybe it's gonna correspond to some
other functions that might edit X as
well so what you can do is you just say
global X and so that's kind of like
defining a variable only you're just
basically saying one of the variables is
going to be the global variable X so now
let's run that and bring this over
and run tears and sure enough we didn't
get in here now let's print X and see if
it did indeed work so save that run it
again there we go
so sure enough five six and then does it
continue outside of the function well
yes it does and so I was trying to think
of how we can do this okay what we'll do
is because otherwise it you wouldn't see
that it worked so we'll call test first
and then it'll print X so then you
should see if you know five six six save
that run it and sure enough we did see
five six six so that's an example of an
unbound local error and how global
variables work and what you can do to
get around it I this was probably one of
the most annoying errors I had to deal
with when I was learning to program
because it just made no sense to me
because I was able to call it but then
as soon as I try to modify it it was
like it's referenced for a sign man what
the heck are you talking about and it
was just it was definitely killer but
anyway that's that hopefully you guys
enjoyed hopefully I helped some of you
guys out as always thanks for watching